HUNGARIAN CAMERA WOMAN CAN BE
SEEN KICKING AND TRIPPING
REFUGEES, ADULTS AND CHILDREN
ALIKE.
>> Reporter: A SHOCKING VIDEO
GARNERED ATTENTION FROM AROUND
THE WORLD AS WAVES OF DESPERATE
MIGRANTS SPRINT FROM A HOLDING
CAMP IN HUNGARY, A KA RA WOMAN
APPEARS TO TRIP A MAN RUNNING
WITH HIS CHILD IN HIS ARMS.
HE FALLS TO THE GROUND ON TOP OF
THE BOY AND SCREAMS IN
DISBELIEF.
THE WOMAN ALSO KICKS OTHER
MIGRANTS AS THEY RUN INCLUDING A
YOUNG GIRL.
NOW THE CAMERA WOMAN IS OUT OF A
JOB.
SHE WAS COVERING THE FLOOD OF
MIGRANTS FOR THE FAR RIGHT
STATION.
IT OFFERS NEWS FROM A
NATIONALIST PERSPECTIVE.
IN A STATEMENT, THE STATION SAID
THE CAMERA OPERATOR BEHAVIOR WAS
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
HER EMPLOYMENT WILL BE
TERMINATED.
THE STATION DID NOT DISCLOSE HER
IDENTITY.
SOCIAL MEDIA DID.
CNN CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRM
HER NAME.
WE ARE NOT IDENTIFYING HER.
THOUSAND TOOK TO A FACE BOOK
SHAME WALL TO CRITICIZE WLT MAN
THEY BELIEVE IS RESPONSIBLE.
ON TWITTER PEOPLE VENTED JUT
RAGE WITH TWEETS, THESE PEOPLE
ARE STRUGGLING FOR A LIFE.
YOU HAVE A LIFE.
YET THIS IS WHAT YOU DO?
SHAME ON YOU.
SHE IS RUNNING FOR HER LIFE,
ANOTHER WROTE.
YOU ARE DESTROYING HER LIFE AND
YOU ARE EARNING MONEY FOR IT.
IS SHE HUMAN?
AND, THAT PHOTOGRAPHER SHOULD BE
CHARGED WITH ASSAULT.
CRIMINAL ACT.
CRIMINAL CHARGES ARE INDEED
POSSIBLE.
THERE ARE REPORTS HUNGARY'S
OPPOSITION PARTIES WILL PURSUE